Ab wann ist man eigentlich computerspielabhängig?
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO hat dieses
Jahr im Entwurf der 11.
Revision des ICD der International Statistical
Classification of Diseases, das ist quasi
das weltweite Verzeichnis von Krankheiten,
exzessives Gaming als psychische Störung
eingeführt.
Jetzt ist es also amtlich.
Un das hier ist quasi die amtliche Bekanntmachung.
Jetzt gibt es keine Ausreden mehr bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich spannende
Science-Videos Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich wiilkommen.
Eine Computerspielabhängigkeit wird im ICD
der International Statistical Classification
of Diseases als Gaming-Disorder bezeichnet
und ist unter dem Schlüssel 6C51 aufgeführt,
womit sie im Bereich der mentalen, Verhaltens-
und Neuroentwicklungsstörungen eingeordnet
ist.
Allerdings streiten Fachleute über die Berechtigung
des exzessiven Gamings als eigenständiges
Störungsbild.
Eigentliche gesunde Kinder und Jugendliche
laufen Gefahr zu Unrecht stigmatisiert und
diagnostiziert zu werden.
Die Entwicklung von Videospielen der letzten
Jahre zeigt, dass Zocken mittlerweile wohl
im Alltag etabliert und normal ist.
Digitale Spiele sind in bestimmten Lebensphasen
von besonderer Bedeutung – wie auch andere
Freizeitaktivitäten auch- und daher ist das
Spielen von Videospielen, selbst wenn es häufiger
vorkommen sollte, nicht gänzlich ungewöhnlich.
Wenn sich allerdings Fachleute dieser Medienrealität
versperren, laufen sie Gefahr die Gaming-Sucht
fehl zu diagnostizieren und dabei andere Störungen
wie Depressionen zu übersehen.
Also: Ab wann gilt man nach Fachmeinung als
computerspielsüchtig und was passiert mit
einem?
Videospielsucht wird durch ein tiefgreifendes
Muster anhaltenden oder wiederholten Spielens
von Computerspielen (da fasse ich jetzt mal
alle elektronischen oder Softwaregesteuerte
Spiele zusammen) charakterisiert.
Das kann online und offline sein.
Die Symptome: Eingeschränkte Kontrolle über
das Spielen (z.B.
Beginn, Häufigkeit, Intensität, Dauer, Beenden)
Zunehmende Priorität für das Spielen in
dem Maße, dass es wichtiger wird als andere
Interessen im Leben wie Freundschaften zum
Beispiel und alltägliche Aktivitäten.
Fortsetzung oder Steigerung des Spielens trotz
Auftretens negativer Konsequenzen.
Für die Diagnose eine Gaming-Sucht muss das
Verhaltensmuster ausreichend stark sein.
Dazu gehören beispielsweise erhebliche Beeinträchtigungen
der persönlichen, familiären, sozialen,
schulischen oder beruflichen Funktionsbereiche,
die mindestens 12 Monate lang offensichtlich
sind.
So jetzt habt ihr es.
Und wenn ihr erfahren wollt, wie das bei Fortnite
süchtig macht, dann schaut euch das Video
von GeRannyMo an: Macht Fortnite süchtig?
- Eine Gaming-Psychologische Analyse um den
Hype Hier geht es zum Abo von GeRannyMo und
ansonsten: Bis dann!
Bleibt dran!